Trascrizione: Margherita Molettieri
Revisore: Dario Canossi
Disegnavo labirinti
tutti rigorosamente senza via di uscita.
Ero un’adolescente
e mi passavo i bigliettini con le mie amiche.
Volevo raccontare come vivevo la vita in quel momento
e quali erano i miei problemi
e non riuscivo a descriverli a parole,
avevo bisogno di rappresentarli
e così ho trovato i labirinti.
Solo che non riuscivo a uscirne:
quindi erano tutti senza via di uscita.
Però non potevo non uscirne,
avevo bisogno di andare avanti,
non si poteva rimanere lì fermi
e allora, a un certo punto, ho deciso
che se la via di uscita non esisteva,
avrei dovuto crearmela
e quindi ho iniziato a far saltare i labirinti.
Ho scoperto quali erano i vincoli
e ho deciso di farli saltare
per trovare una scappatoia
perché quando uno ha un problema,
deve superarlo, deve risolverlo,
deve andare avanti e deve,
soprattutto se lo riguarda personalmente,
deve sempre riuscirci.
Il video che abbiamo visto all’inizio, secondo me,
era incredibilmente ispiratore
perché un problema, in un certo senso, è un drago
e riuscire a risolvere un problema
significa riuscire a domare il drago.
Però domare il drago significa anche
riuscire a non snaturarlo
e quindi il volo sui droni è un
pezzo del domare il drago, no?
Prendere il volo insieme al vostro drago
e farsi ispirare dal drago stesso.
La prima cosa che capita
quando uno deve risolvere un problema
di solito è identificare il problema.
Se vi capita di fare questa cosa per lavoro,
tipicamente arriverete e vi diranno:
ho questo problema.
Spesso quello che vi raccontano non è corretto,
nel senso che vi stanno raccontando un sintomo,
che però non è il vero problema.
Quindi la prima cosa da fare per partire
è riuscire a identificare un problema.
Se voi guardate questa frase
e magari la leggete rapidamente,
coglierete una bellissima
frase di Aristotele che dice:
la speranza è un sogno fatto da svegli.
Ma se vi concentrate
e la riguardate,
vi renderete conto che c’è qualcosa che non torna
perché la prima e l’ultima lettera sono giuste
e anche quelle in mezzo,
ma sono un po’ tutte scombinate.
Perché?
Perché stiamo dando una rappresentazione diversa.
A una prima occhiata riuscite a leggerla,
se vi concentrate no.
Ed è sulla seconda occhiata che bisogna andare avanti
e iniziare a indagare.
La seconda cosa importante da fare
quando affrontate un problema
è iniziare a capire un po’ quali sono i ruoli.
Io sono un’appassionata di Mahjong
che è un gioco, un solitario,
chiamiamolo così,
abbastanza semplice.
Dovete trovare le coppie di tile uguali
all’interno di questo schema.
Ogni volta che cambio l’applicazione con cui sto giocando
o il programmino installato su un computer diverso,
la cosa che cambia sempre,
al di là della disposizione di queste tile,
è che cosa c’è disegnato sopra
e la prima vera difficoltà
è riuscire a memorizzare i diversi disegni
per riuscire ad accoppiarli subito.
I ruoli all’interno di un progetto,
dal quale derivano poi dei problemi,
non sono necessariamente,
immediatamente evidenti
perché magari vi diranno
che il capo progetto è una persona
e poi nella realtà dei fatti vi renderete conto
che non è lui quello che sta guidando
e così vi diranno
che una persona è molto brava a fare qualcosa
e magari è vero,
però poi ci sono anche delle emozioni
che finiscono all'interno del progetto
dei sottotesti, delle parti precedenti
che vanno a creare nuovi problemi
e che vanno tutti quanti presi in considerazione.
E poi un'altra cosa importante da fare
è provare a iniziare a valutare le soluzioni.
Un problema può avere:
nessuna soluzione
o può avere tante soluzioni.
Le soluzioni vanno considerate tutte
e probabilmente la maggior parte andranno scartate
perché magari sono già state prese in considerazione
e considerate inutili
oppure perché non si possono applicare in quel campo
perché ci sono dei vincoli di soldi, di tempo,
di tutto quello che volete,
che non la rendono la soluzione migliore
e poi una soluzione potrebbe anche essere
decidere che non c'è una soluzione,
che dato che il problema ha dato una serie di vincoli
che sono assolutamente inamovibili
l'unica soluzione è dire:
ok, questo problema lo rimettiamo nel cassetto
e lo ritireremo fuori tra un altro pochino
quando possiamo permetterci di affrontarlo.
La cosa più semplice, se volete, del risolvere i problemi
è che risolvere i problemi degli altri
tutto sommato è una passeggiata
rispetto a risolvere i propri problemi.
Perché?
Perché siamo esterni, no?
Arrivare su un progetto e
guardarne i problemi da fuori
è una cosa veramente,
non dico semplice,
però insomma ha una facilità incredibile
rispetto a chi il progetto l’ha costruito,
ci ha lavorato sopra ed è
arrivato fino a quel punto.
Se lavorate con un’azienda
che non conoscete
e che è magari grande,
potete concedervi il lusso di dimenticarvi
di tutta una serie di problemi che riguardano la burocrazia,
piuttosto che i flussi autorizzativi interni,
piuttosto che delle dinamiche di favori e di scambi
all’interno dei diversi dipartimenti,
semplicemente perché non li conoscete.
E quindi iniziate a proporre delle soluzioni
che poi magari,
per tutte le ragioni che vi ho elencato, verranno scartate,
ma magari in qualche caso una di queste
sarà la soluzione interessante per il problema
perché non avete considerato dei vincoli
che non vi sono stati trasmessi
e che quindi non esistevano.
Tutti i vincoli sarebbe bene che venissero identificati,
ma tutti i vincoli che sono pertinenti per quel problema,
non necessariamente i vincoli ambientali
che citavo pochi minuti fa.
Una volta trovati tutti i vincoli,
uno può anche scegliere deliberatamente
di ignorarne qualcuno.
Nel mio labirinto iniziale c’erano troppi vincoli
e io non riuscivo a uscirne.
Quindi ho deciso,
beh, lì era facile,
di farli saltare in aria tutti quanti.
Di solito si sceglie di farne saltare uno,
quello più debole o quello che vi vincola di più.
E si va avanti.
Perché tolto un vincolo,
magari il problema diventa più facile da risolvere.
E poi non tutti i problemi sono uguali.
In questa immagine c’è citato un algoritmo,
il 'divide et impera'
che significa molto semplicemente
che alcuni problemi possono essere suddivisi
in sotto-problemi
e andare a risolvere un sotto-problema
potrebbe essere molto più semplice
che risolvere tutto il problema.
Se il problema è un problema, come dire, ideale,
posso andare a risolvere
tutti i sotto-problemi che riesco a identificare
e ho trovato la soluzione finale.
Ma spesso i problemi non sono fatti così,
di solito hanno tutta una serie di sotto-problemi,
che posso svincolare e risolvere,
che però non mi aiutano nella soluzione del mio problema
perché il mio problema è talmente grande
che ha bisogno di essere affrontato tutto insieme.
Una cosa di cui non si può fare a meno
per risolvere problemi
è pensare.
E non è un’attività
di quelle che uno si può mettere alla scrivania e dire:
stamattina penso e risolvo il mio problema,
perché non funziona.
Perché le idee,
se fosse così facile farsele venire,
veramente, io non avrei più un lavoro,
non avremmo più problemi da risolvere.
Io risolvo problemi la mattina sotto la doccia,
soprattutto dopo una bella notte di sonno,
perché nelle notti di sonno penso, penso moltissimo.
Il famoso consiglio del ‘dormiteci sopra’
per me è fondamentale,
non tanto perché non dormo e sto sveglia con i miei pensieri,
ma perché nel sonno, mentre sogno, tra una cosa e l’altra,
la mente si libera
e, allora, se, quando sono andata a dormire,
la strada che andava da A a B era una linea retta
che univa questi due punti
ed era la soluzione che probabilmente avrei trovato
stando seduta alla mia scrivania,
nella notte mi sono immaginata n-mila strade
che portavano da A a B,
una diversa dall’altra e ciascuna con la sua peculiarità.
Mi è capitato di mettermi di notte al buio
e di svegliarmi con un’idea
e di aprire il comodino, tirare fuori una penna
e mettermi a scrivere, senza accendere la luce
perché altrimenti mi sarei svegliata del tutto
e non sarebbe stata la stessa cosa.
Per risolvere problemi servono veramente tante cose,
ma non sono degli strumenti che potete mettere in valigia.
È un processo complesso
e incredibilmente affascinante.
Io dico che è come domare un drago
perché in un certo senso
servono assolutamente gli stessi skill,
serve immaginazione e creatività
perché le soluzioni non sono ovvie
e non è come risolvere un’equazione
e per risolvere un problema
non sempre uno più uno può fare due.
Serve la capacità di unire i puntini
e serve saper osservare
perché quando dovete fare l’analisi
dovete riuscire a vedere tutto quanto
e serve anche la capacità di modellare.
Quando analizzate un problema
e quando ce lo avete chiaro in testa,
provate a chiudere gli occhi un attimo
e a disegnarlo, così come lo vedete,
nello schema che preferite,
che sia un disegno creativo,
che siano dei box uniti o una lista di elementi
per essere certi di averlo in mano.
Se non riuscite a disegnarlo
e se il disegno che fate non è un disegno
che per voi è coerente,
allora c’è ancora qualcosa che non va,
dovete andare avanti e indagare
perché non lo state padroneggiando,
il vostro drago vi sta ancora scappando dalle mani.
Servono anche delle doti relazionali
perché le soluzioni di un
problema sono sempre tante
e la soluzione migliore
non è probabilmente quella che
voi avete immaginato,
la soluzione migliore è quella che andate a negoziare
con chi ha questo problema
e quindi è la soluzione migliore per lui
in quel momento, in quel contesto
e riuscire a venderla è una delle parti fondamentali,
perché se siete il miglior solutore di questo mondo,
ma siete spocchiosi e arroganti
e la vostra soluzione è quella migliore
perché vi dimostra che io sono
molto più brava di voi,
tendenzialmente prenderete la mia soluzione
e la butterete via
perché non vi interessa,
perché si porta dietro talmente tanto
che è estraneo alla soluzione del problema
che non è il caso di tenercela.
E altre cose che sono importanti per la soluzione di problemi
è parlare.
Parlare con gli altri,
ma anche parlare con una paperella gialla,
esattamente come quando lo state modellando,
raccontare quel modello a voce alta
per vedere se ha qualche baco
e se riuscite a raccontarlo correttamente,
un pezzetto dopo l’altro e dicendolo a voce alta,
vi rendete assolutamente conto
se quello che state dicendo ha senso,
è un altro pezzo importante.
E potete dirlo a chiunque,
alla prima persona che incontrate per strada,
al vostro vicino di scrivania,
alla paperella gialla come fanno i programmatori
perché non c’è bisogno di
un’interazione in questa fase,
ma semplicemente c’è bisogno di chiarirsi le idee
e essere certi di averle chiare
e poi anche fare brainstorming aiuta moltissimo
perché nel momento in cui siete lì
e state discutendo con qualcuno
e lanciate delle idee,
le idee sono sempre importanti
perché si portano dietro altre idee.
La parte più interessante di un brainstorming
non è che arriviamo in fondo con la soluzione,
è che arriviamo in fondo con i cervelli accesi
che vanno a mille perché abbiamo tirato fuori tantissime idee
e molte di queste non sono pertinenti a questo problema,
però le posso usare da un’altra parte,
e altre ancora sono molto interessanti,
non sono applicabili in questo caso,
ma hanno uno schema che posso riutilizzare,
c’è qualcosa che posso prendere da quell’idea
e applicarla in questo caso
perché ci ho visto del buono dentro.
E poi c’è un motivo profondo
se questa presentazione si intitola 'Capitani coraggiosi'
e non 'Il problem solving secondo me'.
Perché quando affrontate un problema
e domate, alla fin fine, il vostro drago,
dovete tenere conto anche
della componente emozionale di questa esperienza,
perché la vostra soluzione in realtà non è una soluzione,
in alcuni casi sì,
ma nella maggior parte dei casi
e soprattutto quando il vostro problema è veramente grosso,
non è una soluzione, è una visione.
E se volete trasferire la vostra visione,
dovete coinvolgere emotivamente
le persone che stanno lavorando con voi.
Il vostro problema deve farvi paura
e dovete affrontare questa paura
e se volete che vi seguano e che l’apprezzino,
devono sapere che avete avuto paura
e che questa paura l’avete superata
per seguire la vostra visione
e salpare insieme a voi
e prendere quest’onda.
E allora spero che adesso voi siate pronti
a far saltare i vostri labirinti,
che abbiate scoperto
che tutto sommato si può
avere un certo amore per il tritolo
e se non ne siete del tutto convinti
potete provare a canticchiare
un vecchio De André d’annata
quando cantava del Bombarolo. Grazie.